son dernier rôle dans green book de
peter farrelly lui a valu une nomination
aux golden globes et a fait de lui un
candidat sérieux à l'oscar à 60 ans
viggo mortensen est un acteur
mondialement connus dont on sait
finalement peu de choses thomas qui est
3h abassi sur le portrait d'un paradoxe
d'une star qui a choisi de vivre à
l'écart du système hollywoodien non
mortensen prénom vigo ce qui signifie
guerrier en danois à 60 ans film notable
le seigneur des anneaux a history of
violence les promesses de l'ombre mais
aussi la route où ces jours-ci greenbook
le premier film sans son frère de peter
farrelly l'auteur de mary à tout prix de
dumb et dumber aux idéogrammes ans
au dos reis particularité tous à tous
viggo mortensen ne tourne quasiment plus
que pour le cinéma indépendant à travers
une filmographie d'esthète loin des
grosses machines hollywoodiennes qui
l'avait révélé au monde telle
perspective cette année alors que viggo
était déjà nommé aux golden globes en
tant que meilleur acteur l'humanisme de
green book pourrait bien le lancer sur
la route de la consécration ultime celle
des oscars
ce cash profond un arbre acteurs
polyglotte et la lutte ou camus il a
grandi entre le venezuela l'argentine le
danemark et les états unis
il habite en espagne mais nous répond en
français ouais je peux je peux le faire
rencontre avec un acteur un peu plus
libre que les autres
il a été barman routier et même docker
et aujourd'hui les peintres musiciens
réalisateurs scénaristes poète
photographe éditeur je dors pas mais
viggo mortensen et surtout acteur haus
der s'orienter vers vokoun sa dette
envers ces modèles ont d'abord été des
actrices renée falconetti anna magnani
meryl streep au début ingrid bergman et
liv ullmann quelques rôles que j'ai vu
je poussais commentait ce qu'on fait ça
que moi
le spectateur je suis là et je crois
tout pendant un temps vigo a tourné pour
être coupée au montage ou pour
n'apparaître quand des rôles secondaires
mais malgré tout il a quand même joué
pour jane campion ridley scott tony
scott ou gus van sant tu es il a partagé
l'affiché avec des noms aussi
prestigieux que sean penn
al pacino ou bien que vous n'êtes pas le
trou et michael douglas dans meurtre
parfait un remake d'hitchcock
qui aurait un jour on lui propose le
rôle d'aragorn dans le seigneur des
anneaux à cannes shopping c'est pas très
tentée l'acteur hésite et c'est son fils
de 11 ans qui le pousse à y aller à fond
dans le seigneur des anneaux il a peu de
dialogues watts cei il chante un tout
petit peu
tous
mais ce qu'on a retenu c'est qu'il est
particulièrement intense attention
intense alerte en quantité intensité
maximum quoi qu'il en soit avec le
seigneur des anneaux il obtient la
reconnaissance d'un public mondial mais
les millions d'entrées tout comme le
statut d'acteur star ne l'intéresse pas
plus que ça ces caches et viggo
mortensen les a en partie investie dans
la création d'une maison d'édition
perceval presse son autre vie une maison
avec laquelle il publie notamment des
effets mais aussi ses propres recueil de
poésie car oui quand il ne tourne pas
viggo mortensen écrit quelques vers de
poésie et c'est toujours un travail
d'apprendre à coeur de transmettre ce
camp qu'on boit ce qu'on écoute ce qu'on
sent viggo mortensen semine librement et
revient aussitôt au cinéma d'auteur en
véritable acteur indépendant
ça m'est égal ci est deuxième à quatre
caméras une caméra
une équipe de 10 personnes 2
trois cents personnes le travail seul
même avec le cinéaste canadien david
cronenberg il tourne history of violence
les promesses de l'ombre et aux deux
jours aux méthodes dans lequel il
devient sigmund freud 3 rôle puissant et
noir qui le révèle définitivement à la
phase de la cinéphilie et qui lui valent
ses premières grandes nomination en tant
que meilleur acteur
décidément viggo mortensen est une
anomalie de l'industrie
cinématographique il ne s'installe
jamais nulle part n'aime que les
contre-pieds et c'est ainsi qu'en 2017
on le retrouve à la fiche de captain
fantastic un film plus colorés mêlant
philosophie et mélancolie à travers le
récit d'un père élevant ses enfants loin
de toute civilisation
cela dit elle
des anr c'était en 2017 et déjà les
oscars et les golden globes poser son
nom sur le lit des nominations
malheureusement cette année là c'est
qu'ici affleck qui repart avec la
récompense ou l'eau froide
aujourd'hui avec green book viggo
mortensen étonne encore loin des débats
sur le marxisme de captain fantastic
l'acteur incarne un américain d'origine
italienne en pâte et boulimique brutale
et tendre raciste ordinaire des sixties
chargé de conduire un pianiste de génie
et d'une autre couleur que la sienne à
travers les territoires les plus
hostiles au noir de l'amérique joe klein
pour appuyer et à la cathine qui tombe à
point nommé en cette période trouble de
l'histoire des états unis
ce film peut être utile
demain dans quinze ans dans 20 ans car
la discrimination le racisme ça reste
c'est toujours la même chose on est
comme ça aux golden globes greenbook est
repartie avec trois récompenses et le
film est pressenti pour les oscars face
à des machines comme star is born
comment was being born mécanique et puis
sinon le comédien mortensen pourra
toujours se consoler en relisant les
vers du poète vigo not knowing me
knowing something vous c'est beau savoir
pas savoir